the Trump administration is considering
a perspective prospective offer from
Republican donor Sheldon Adelson to pay
for part of the soon-to-be relocated US
Embassy in Jerusalem there are questions
about whether that would be permitted or
politically wise and how fast it will
happen
correspondent Richardson is here tonight
with that could even rich hi good
evening bread and State Department
attorneys are looking into it whether an
American citizen can legally help pay
for a United States Embassy the State
Department official tells FOX News the
government has received no official
offer from Sheldon Adelson and there
have been no formal discussions about
the donation though the official refused
to rule out informal or unofficial talks
or offers between the two critics claim
a donation from a profoundly pro-israel
Republican donor would allow other
politically active groups to follow and
inject even more politics into an
already sensitive situation this as
State Department officials say secretary
Tillerson has just approved a security
plan to open the u.s. embassy in an
existing facility in Jerusalem by May in
time for the 70th anniversary of the
State of Israel well ahead of the
administration's 2019 target and
fulfilling a presidential campaign
promise it's the right thing to do we
have to go and I didn't
but every other president really lie
because they campaigned on it that was
always a big part of the campaign then
they got into office they never did the
official stresses the new US Embassy
will only have a footprint in Jerusalem
by May with the target still of opening
a larger presence there by the end of
2019 the State Department says initially
the interim embassy will have an office
for the Ambassador and a small staff
officials say separately the State
Department is looking for a site to
build a permanent US Embassy in
Jerusalem a longer term project
Brett rich thanks